I'd like to take a quick temperature
check of the audience who is running
what you would call micro services in
production today at your company a lot
of people okay good who is running more
than 60 of them in parallel at your
company today okay fewer okay there's
some challenges still to overcome in
getting up this road and a lot of you
didn't even raise your hand because
you're not running them in production
pay attention then because you're as you
make this journey you're going to need
this information pretty soon a structure
of our talk today first I'm going to
talk about this journey to cloud native
micro services and why it's a great
place to make them resilient and make
your developers focusing on the pieces
you want them to John from blundell will
talk about his experience of this and
his team's experience going through
exactly this story I've Lendl and then
in the second half after Jon I will go
in a bit more technical details about
microcircuits I don't think that's my
phone
okay good we have our little behind
schedule so we will speed up accelerates
through some pieces of it if we skip
over some stuff that you really wish you
knew that you think is the most
important part sorry we will be hanging
out here at the end of the stage please
come up and just ask us hey what about
that you skipped over that too fast I
didn't understand we'd like to share so
from a background I am a software
developer by background I spent a lot of
years doing it I love it but the
challenges be can be hard and these days
it's not really getting any easier to be
a software developer so in the old days
the good old days we like to imagine
them this was all I had to worry about
right I would write my code I would
compile it I would ship it to the users
they would install it they would call me
with some annoying support questions
sometimes usually a peb CAC error or
something like that and then we would
write a new version compile it ship it
to them again that was that was it that
was simple I could focus on this
business problem that my product owner
we didn't call them that back then that
my business needed to solve or my
customer
salt would make us more money and then
things started to get a little more
complicated but it's still pretty simple
right we had a client that's a Palm
Pilot not an Android so you know how old
I am the we we had you know a Java
back-end where we stuck everything the
authentication inventory management
rules a logging library it was probably
just one server back then or one time it
was my laptop because we couldn't deploy
it into the server room so we stuck my
laptop into the data center with a note
saying don't unplug this please okay so
you know it's not necessarily the good
old days there was a database managed by
a DBA she would really help us out with
tuning the index and planning this stuff
but we were really you know we had to
all work together and we thought a lot
about software architecture patterns
best practices but it was still three
monoliths that were tightly coupled
together which is actually we we still
ship and compile them on all big chunks
but on a roll out we have to coordinate
with downtime and we really actually had
one scattered monolith which we've made
lives a lot more hard hard of ourselves
fast forward many many years a lot has
happened the next stage in that journey
is this explosive growth of the internet
new technologies world press photos was
talking to you about the fact that they
really times are changing companies need
to move faster because the environments
faster so we start decomposing our
scattered monoliths into micro servers
that we can test and deploy individually
and faster keep functionality alive
that's micro services we build up
automation services for better
deployments to keep these systems alive
and our modern applications start to
look a little bit like this oh that's
not three-tier that's a whole bunch of
stuff we got we got we got to separate
it across zones so that if one's whole
zone dies it stays alive we keep serving
to our users we've got oh but now that
they're separated we need to load
balance between those machines and those
machines and we need to have
coordination of state between them so he
has task queues and oh wait health
checks and that need to be coordinated
and Wow it just got complicated because
what I want as a developer to care
is this this little piece this red piece
my product owner wants me to build it I
need to build it to make money for my
business or my customers too I want to
knock a new feature out the door every
week but in order to do that I have to
understand all of this in order for my
application to live here I got to
understand what's happening I can't just
write my Java code or write my Python
code and Trust it's gonna go well and
not just me and that's just my team's
but each of the 20 other deployment
teams running the 60 other micro
services we have to have all have to
have the same picture use their head
cycles understanding this stay
consistent about how they do it
otherwise you're in trouble so and
pieces of this infrastructure start
creeping into my code how do I handle
back off requests how do I configure how
do I find those services stuff that I
shouldn't have to write into my code
that makes it harder to operate my own
code because of this infrastructure my
application shouldn't care that it's
running in this it should just run and
that the environment should take care of
it so and this is without even touching
on these many other complicated parts of
it that start creeping into my code my
team might be using a completely
different tooling than the other team
because they evaluated their problem
they said you know what go is the right
thing for us to use we need high
streaming throughput another team says
you know what dotnet is the right thing
for this my team says no we love Python
there's no good reason for it just just
religious reasons and that happens
sometimes but you know there's usually a
good reason so it interest of time I'm
gonna skip all over these I think you
all recognize these what I really want
to do is write some code to solve a
business problem to make it fun for me
because I like that I like knocking a
new feature out every week to create a
new business opportunity to make money
for my customers or whatever so what
happened right it's not the writing of
the code that get hard that's still fun
knocking out these problems every week
running that code in production keeping
alive with the requirements of the crazy
modern times it's creating all sorts of
complexity for our teams so in the good
old days we would write our code we'd
pass it to the QA team for testing
they'd send it back to us five times
we'd give it to the ops teams and we're
done it's not my problem they take care
of it in my company in my old days from
we were pretty friendly we knew each
other we liked each other so we would
refer to them as those poor bastards who
had to handle the crap we gave them and
had a lot of out of memory errors and
stuff like that and they would talk to
call us those idiots who keep sending us
this stuff and we had a positive
relationship right so we have silos and
silos inefficiencies caught it really
boils down to cost and slowness we all
know what I'm talking about
today we've moved ahead many years
nowadays it's your problem it's your
team's problem remember DevOps is not a
title or it shouldn't be just a title of
someone on your team it's a whole team
culture so the QA is now the problem of
every person on the team you're
responsible for the code you ship that
the deployment works if you're causing
out of memory errors someone's going to
tell your team about it and they fix it
this is why it works but you just want
to focus on that application so you're
gonna need a tooling to make this not
your problem or at least a solved
problem what would this look like in an
ideal world for a development team and
an ops team you know a company trying to
run all this together you want every one
of your developer teams to write what
they want in a way that they can in the
language they want and deploy it in the
same way W more don't worry you want
that app to just be play you just want
to say here's the application the
structure I want make it so and it's
gonna live in this environment just I
don't want to have to worry about it and
hopefully you don't have to deal with
the physical machines themselves right
it's just you need a place for this
application to run this environment is
gonna give them the space to run that
you don't have to stress out about so
what would such a solution look like in
the modern cloud world well we'd have a
we have container packaging for
predictable deployment dynamic
scheduling to make sure that our
application found a place to run and
recomputing that when necessary and it's
gotta be micro services oriented right
it's got to be something that supports
this type of thing reusability of code
fast future release loose coupling so
let's start the journey and wow we're
really short on time unless this clocks
a little started before I got on stage
you know we tried this returnee on VMs
it didn't quite deliver we never quite
got the the efficiency that we wanted we
never quite got the automation we wanted
it works but it requires a lot of extra
work just skipping ahead from that why
the modern developer world and the
DevOps and the ops teams are falling in
love with containers right we abstract
the way the operating system that
containers your application only needs
to think about its interfaces with other
applications in your environment it
doesn't need to think about all these
load balancing things they give our
development teams a consistent way to
package our applications and deliver
them and dependencies so my laptop
doesn't end up in the data center again
it's a great solution to many of these
problems and if we only had one machine
that never failed and never ran out of
resources we'd put them all on it and
life would be good and we'd be done but
that's not the real world either so we
figured out Dockers are great containers
are great but now we have a new set of
challenges computers everything you
solve oh there's a new challenge behind
it so once we fall in love with
containers we try to build a system with
50 services micro services built out of
500 running containers across 30
machines and we discover that there's a
new layer of complexity how we do these
things luckily Google has some
experience with this we've been running
containers in our data centers for 12
years so we have so we start about 2
billion containers a week Gmail search
maps
everything you touch at Google you're
touching a container it's running on a
container the point of that is we have
some experience at understanding how to
structure containers in production and
run them efficiently so about two and a
half or three years ago we launched this
really cool open source project called
kubernetes we took the lessons we've
learned we package them up into an
open-source community we gave it to the
Linux Foundation or the cloud native
computing foundation recruited community
members like crazy
tons of people doing stuff on it and
basically we built kubernetes to solve
this problem we wanted to expose the way
we work to the world we wanted people to
be able to do this
it's a great Orchestrator for your
containers in production you can run it
anywhere but when you run it at Google a
lot of things are automatically handled
for you like the master which is your
control point I don't have any
architecture diagrams about that it runs
in it runs it's managed by Google so you
don't have to worry about upgrades nodes
the mass you tell the master the way you
want your application to look it gives
you the nodes to run on if you need more
or less it takes care of that it decides
where to stick those applications it
routes
traffic's to them so outside users can
find them and your internal services can
find them and it's responsible for
setting up and keeping it that way as
life goes on and things break and things
change so before I'm gonna go into
technical details after in the second
part but first I'm gonna hand it over to
jean merits the CTO of glendol his
company has been on this journey for a
while and he's going to share his
information about that experience moving
into micro services from mano list of
micro services and how cuber net has
helped them with that so Shaun come on
up thanks for joining me thanks man
thank you morning everyone so I'm going
to try to be as enthusiastic as Matt was
just now but those are some tough shoes
to fill so bear with me
so just a quick question first
who of you have heard of blended before
great quite some hands and for those of
you who didn't raise your hand let me
just quickly introduce you to a product
so bland little is an online Kiehl's
that helps you find the journalism and
background stories that are interested
to you we present you the best stories
you should read every morning and
deliver them to you via email the apps
native apps that we have etc there are
no pay walls no ads you just it is you
and great journalism u8a you need to pay
with a few cents per article or let's
January we launched dental premium which
you pay a fixed fee every month and we
sent you a selection of articles that
are most interested to you we also have
establish a doctors who make sure that
we try to brush your filter bubble every
day again once you click on an article
you can read it and we are very proud of
DUI and UX that we put a lot of time in
so this is the interface that you get
when you read and you can see it's all
about you and a story it's presented in
the way that the author meant it to be
read so there are no ads no annoying
pop-ups and we have a huge selection of
newspapers and magazines you can pick
from
you see Bloomberg Businessweek Time
magazine we also have New York Times
economist Mother Jones well she journal
The New Yorker etc etc etc so there's
always something interested to you if
you want to check out more go to blammo
comm or download the apps in the App
Store but let's talk about while you're
here let's talk about our technical
stack so we're currently got 32
employees actually 32 engineers working
on our product we are a particular
development environment which means we
use Ruby for back-end stuff but we also
use Python for data scientists we use go
along for where we need performance and
a lot of other languages and this is
something which we're going to wear
containers really helped we've also got
native apps and a website which is built
with react and we started out with a
monolid but which startup doesn't and
we'll also get into that because it's
important to realize that starting with
a monolith is key to understanding how
you're going to implement micro services
but in the past year we've been slowly
but surely splitting off my service from
that monolith so let me give you some
context there are some numbers here
about our production applications the
most interesting ones we are generating
more than 50 million personalised
bundles every month and we're sending
more than 400 thousand personalized
newsletters and under 10 minutes to all
of our customers and this is really key
when you look at micro services because
depending on the needs that you have for
your small part of your application you
might decide to build your application
in a specific way or with a specific
language if you need simplicity you use
a language that's easy to work with and
easy to understand if you need
performance you use C++ or go or
whatever so it's key to understand your
application and when to use what so our
journey brought us from the MA
on bare metal - micro-services on a
container base cloud infrastructure and
there's more to come in the coming years
I'm sure of that there is a big
community around us as we saw in the
keynote earlier so let's talk about that
monolith it used to be and still is a
ruby base API with JavaScript front-end
and native apps communicating with the
API and surrounding that API where are
lots of different object stores
databases caches proxies etcetera etc
but they're all revolved around that
single API and thus were dependent on
that API always working we did manual
deployment is using Capistrano we did we
ran our application on three machines
and they were running here in a
datacenter in Amsterdam and we had an
Operations engineer responsible for the
production environment of our product so
there are obviously some pain points
here that we wanted to solve for example
these three manual deployments we can
all agree takes a lot of time and it
includes a higher potential of human
error so you need to get away with that
running a single application on three
machines also means that you're not
using the full utilization of those
machines thus increasing the cost of
running your application and having
development production be managed by
different teams automatically means that
there is less accountability different
people are responsible different parts
different lives that lifecycle stages of
your application and that can complicate
things a lot but the other two could
also be scratch off this list because
like I said before using single api
which has to be performant and easy etc
is difficult there is not one true
language which can handle this all a one
true environment which can handle this
all so we move to micro services we've
been doing this for some time now and
actually what we notice is that the
technology problems aren't the problems
that you should worry about you have a
lot of smart engineers at your company
they know how to solve this but besides
that there are a lot of smart people
working at Google at a red
other companies they put tons of hours
again if he saw early in the keynote put
tons of hours in working on these
projects like Cuban edits to help you
solve those problems in fact it's about
conceptual problems and processes that
intertwine with your stack your
application that's something outside
people can't work on because it's you
your team who has to work on that and
that's what make this interesting
for example the biggest challenge we saw
is that defining what part of your
monolith you're going to split off into
micro service is key you don't just take
apart like this looks like a good block
of content that we can take and put into
a micro service you have to think about
the domain boundaries if you don't do
that you'll actually end up right back
where you started but worse they'll have
monolith split between micro services
which has to communicate over the
networking layer to call different
functions and different in different
micro services and we all know adding a
networking layer increases the risk of
hard to debug errors so always go the
extra mile not to only make sure that
you understand the different domains of
your product but also to prevent too
much chatter and too much type coupling
between your services and this is key to
having a successful micro
service-oriented architecture if you
don't like I said you'll probably end up
back where you were in the beginning a
Martin Fowler who's a famous surf
architect and author
he works at thought works and he's also
one of the original authors of the
manifesto for agile software development
I think he said the best you said almost
all the cases where I've heard of a
system that was built as a micro system
from scratch it has ended up in serious
trouble
you need to have production experience
with your domains in order to understand
where it makes sense to split smoth and
where it doesn't or take it another way
he said almost all the successful micro
stories have started with the monolith
that got too big and was broken up so
this is very important so how does
kubernetes fit into this picture like I
said before once you figure out how you
want to split up your micros
the technology isn't really the problem
Kuban and this will help you with that
part of course it takes time of course
there are challenges to overcome
but as far as we have seen you can
overcome them and there is a big
community around you to help you with
that
I think Cuba netis turned out to be much
more than a simple container schedule
for us it was a way to empower our
employees to experiment and self manage
we actually saw an increase in teams and
individuals deploying simple
applications that they built either at
the end of the day or during a day where
there was nothing else they were working
on or they build some cool project and
weekends
these things can then easily be deployed
to the entire company and then be used
by people and that fosters innovation
and increasing speed of your deployment
cycles so these are some numbers about
our Cuba nets class tonight we hoist our
community are on gge Google container
engine we have eight nodes of h6r p.m.
to both EMS and on those are running 575
parts another 34 services and what's
interesting about this is that because
we use preemptable VMs there will be
talk about this later today I think
about what those are in case you don't
know what they are but to quickly
explain a print of VM allows you to it
it gives you a machine which can at any
time be taken back by Google because it
because I need to resources but you get
a fixed discount steep discount on these
machines and because you're running on
Cuban edits and we are scaling up and we
have multiple replicas per per service
running it doesn't matter if a machine
drops out because the application will
stay up and what it does bring is is a
reduced cost and it brings us automated
chaos monkey like infrastructure where
machines will fill all the time and our
engineers need to be wary of that and
need to design your applications to be
highly available so what does people
Nevers mean for some practice all our
servers are highly available like I said
and even the most simple ones we
replicate at least three times just
because we want to make sure that it's
always running even if it's an internal
application and combined with micro
service would clear to find domain
brownies like I told about earlier
it means we haven't had a complete
failure of our application within
last year and maybe more things do break
of course we're only human but the
impact of something breaking isn't as
big as blenders down it might be as big
as search isn't working or the email is
delayed and it's not on time to our
customers which is bad and we need to
fix that but people can still use our
product and as top of that we went from
a couple of manual deployments every
week to sometimes 50 releases per day
all our applications are automatically
test and automatically deployed so let's
take a quick look at some real-world use
cases for example
blammo button which is a product that we
built where in this case the Volks con
can put it on the website and people can
buy the article with for a few cents
with the wallet they have a blender and
we ship that in a couple of months and
we actually did was this was a first
micro service that we built on top of
kubernetes I think you menem's was still
version o dot nine back then so I wish I
don't try this at home but eventually
things work out also goals is an
interesting use case because a product
manager lead product manager at our
company wanted a tool that could help us
focus on our okrs and on personal goal
setting that we that all engineers have
done will have he built a quick tool use
Ruby on Rails real simple bootstrap for
front-end and he deployed it on our
cluster and everyone is using it at our
company right now so it's really awesome
something like this where two engineers
at blender will build a spreadsheet
which automatically queries the
cumulants API in which every team who
deploys an application to communities
adds a little bit of metadata to
deployment where people can find support
for this application so adding a name
multiple names adding a github repo
adding an email address stuff like that
and then it's automatically constantly
updated in the spreadsheet to for people
to find out for example the support team
like who can I ask about this problem so
these are some examples continuous
deployment is not a big one we are
actually running our contain continuous
deployment pipeline on top of Cuban
editors so we deploy to Cuban editors
from a continued
deployment pipeline which is running on
Cuban Eddie's and it auto skills for
whatever requirements we have at that
moment so if a lot of teams are blowing
at a time
it just Auto scales it adds more nodes
it adds more parts and it's it's able to
deploy in a couple seconds or for bigger
projects in a couple of minutes so to
recap I think starting with a monolid or
at least having a cleaner understanding
on why you need micro services is key if
you use kubernetes and in our example
Google container engine the problem
become less technical you need to focus
on the operational and conceptual parts
of this brought these problems teams
will come self-managed they can release
better they can release more you empower
your teams and as for us
you can release a new service in less
than an hour if someone has an ID they
build something we have a continuous
department pipeline they can ship it
thanks everyone for your time and I'd
like to give it back to Matt thank you
very much sir hey everyone thanks for
letting me back on stage I'll try to I
do need to keep moving fast but I also
try to keep up a little energy through
this next part of the technical story
what is what is it about kubernetes that
makes it such a great place to run many
many micro services in a resilient way
and empower your teams like this cuber
notice has many powerful cases and
features they've been built over the
last two and a half years by the open
source community and Google and other
contributing partners working together
companies like yours companies like
glendol we launched it to the open
source community with the intention of
growing these use cases because we know
how Google use these things we need to
know how you needed to use them and the
communities built up these use cases
underneath all of these tools all of
these things that you wish you could do
with your micro services I would say it
boils down to four key technical
concepts if you understand those four
key couple concepts you understand
everything that's built on top of them
in terms of how the system works and why
it's good for micro services so I'm
going to explain pods replica sets
services and then
labels which is how they all find and
talk to each other through the eye of a
micro service development team pods are
the smallest deployable unit why not a
container well we know from our
experience that there at Google hard-won
experience that sometimes you want to
deploy multiple containers together they
will live and die together they say
share the same cozy Network space that
will always deploy together on the same
node you don't tell cube antennas to
deploy a container you tell it to deploy
a pod
now often a pod will be just one
container right your front-end team
builds a node.js thing it doesn't need
anything else they put it in the compile
it in docker ship it to the registry you
establish your template that this is my
pod that will get deployed on machines
sometimes it's not even something you've
built you're using a new using a
third-party software like elastic search
for your product search kubernetes has
tools in there like to attach a volume
to it and the template says get this
elasticsearch instance get this volume
that it's going to need put five copies
on it up in different nodes you're gonna
take care of it it could also be you
know other languages so say your
streaming team says for high performance
stuff we need to go we also see
something introduced here now a second
container in the same in the same pod we
have this I would call it a sidecar
container you could call it a helper
container or maybe an old-fashioned
language you might call it cross-cutting
concerns say you had something you said
well we need the SSL offloading to
happen in a certain way let's put it
let's have a team build a container
around that we put it in the same pod
our go team doesn't need to know what
happens at go team just gets the message
passed in you know if without this the
go team would have to think all right
now in my application I have to build
this SSL offloading or you know this SSL
piece into my application now it doesn't
care it just gets the information
straight from the other pod so these
sidecar containers really helps you
separate out these cross-cutting
concerns so you have less dependencies
and your developers focus on just the
piece they want and then it gets much
more complicated now you got your Java
team with ten years of experience
and they might have also have a logging
agent that they use that you want to
separate from out of out of their code
or even for instance you know you can
put dotnet core in a container now which
means you can run it on cue burn is my
I've got a customer sitting right there
that does that in production world press
photos was on stage a few minutes ago
they do this in production so like it's
a new world that we can do this stuff
now so on the micro servers decide let's
let's take the big red button that
Blundell wants to deploy what does that
look like in kubernetes world the first
thing we need to know you understand
pods so the next thing to understand is
the replica set this is essentially just
a control loop you tell it you declare
the state you want it to be in it's
responsible for pulling that pod you
want throwing it on it all of the nodes
doesn't matter which ones making sure
that they're running so it's gonna do
these health check loops if a pod dies
which is gonna happen things go wrong
you have an out of memory error a node
crashes the replicas set you you nobody
gets alerted nobody well gets woken up
in the middle of the night
the replica set just notices that and
says oh let me start another one
somewhere else and fixes it it's
basically like the Star Trek you know
make it so so the replica set will
create the state you want and then keep
the state you want as things go wrong in
your environment and things change the
other side of that micro service angle
is the service people need to reach it
you're outside you're outside audience
needs to reach it or you're doing some
internal services a service is a logical
grouping of pods that all have the same
function based on this label selector so
it's using this label looking for
front-end oh I'll just a bug on my slide
it's looking for back-end but it really
it's finding the front-end one so that's
a user interviews ur bugs not the
incoming requests are gonna be load
balanced across all of the pods that
match this means your service gets a
stable virtual IP its own port and it's
even its own DNS name which you can use
for service discovery and routing inside
so all of that is handled for you by
kubernetes you put these two things
together you have your micro service
right
the replica set and the service combined
to make your micro service the replica
sets taking care of the raziel
the service is handling the service
discovery and routing and now BAM
you've got people hitting your big red
button people deploy it on their sites
traffic's gonna hit it there's always
gonna be here
cue brands gonna take care of that for
you your application developers didn't
need to think about all the stuff but
that's not the end of it you know we
don't just create we need to change big
red button goes live it needs a lot of
traffic how do we scale it up as we add
more publishers well it this still
leverages the same core concepts we just
tell the replicas set give me four
instead of three or ten instead of three
and the replica set makes it so bam bam
bam now you've got ten instances the
service just keeps finding them oh I got
to fix that back in front end thing
sorry but we can't always predict what
our scaling needs are right you know
blended selling this they onboard a new
publisher with a millions of visitors
they don't know how fast it's gonna take
off
or maybe they get a sudden burst maybe
an existing publisher with multiple
properties has tested it out on here and
then one day says great let's launch it
on all of New York Times and just puts
it phones sound like BAM ten you know
ten times the visitors that you they
didn't even tell you about right because
you're selling it to them as a
software-as-a-service
you're saying we're gonna manage this
for you and you just do whatever you
want and so they do they surprise you oh
yeah BAM oh we didn't tell you we were
gonna launch to 10 million new visitors
sorry you wanted to be able to scale
this also uses these same core concepts
every pot is reporting its metrics to a
central essential metric system in Cuba
netis internally its hughster and you
create you define the auto scaling rule
in kubernetes for your application again
your application developers don't know
about this they don't care setting a
target a CPU is a common target there's
other ones that you can use say if it's
above 50% average give me more pods
until it's a business around that and
then when it drops below mark this pod
that it doesn't get any new traffic when
it's done serving traffic kill it save
resources I want to use those for other
things so this is all built into these
core it's all built on top of these core
concepts of that we talked about in
kubernetes
other things you want to do with this
micro service you need to do canary
deployments or you want to deploy ab new
big red button you want to deploy the
big blue button or the big green button
or the round red button or you just want
it to behave differently probably user
interface you can handle there's a lot
of strategies for this rolling upgrades
Bluegreen deployments even just a be
testing you want to keep them both alive
for a while you they all use essentially
the same technique built on these core
concepts you have your replica set with
your service your replica set says this
is all a version one you add a new
replica set with version two but a
different label on it for the but the
same label the service just finds it and
groups it in together so you're actually
running these put in parallel you can do
a rolling upgrade with this way where
you add one and remove one it's an
automatic tooling for that or you can
keep them both alive and and measure for
a week a lot of different ways to do it
that's how you do it you've just for
free we could blow them up for free for
a tiny bit of attention from your
engineering or your planning team you
have all of these things in kubernetes
breaking it down what is your single
micro service look like in the cue
brunette cluster the replica set is
where you just specify how many you want
of how many copies of your application
the replica set reaches out to your
registry where all your compiled package
containers are says I need these for
containers or whatever you've defined
and it finds home for them on the nodes
you don't care which nodes they land on
and and puts them out there you define
your service endpoint and now you're
routing traffic your micro service is
live a couple of little things in fact
we even boil it down to one command
called deployments but you can still do
it the old-fashioned way with these
individual pieces if you like that's it
okay I was taking a picture if that's
done okay so that's what your single
micro service looks like but you're a
big company you're running 134 micro
services together you don't just have a
single micro service your team might
think about one but everybody's got to
think about it it's gonna look more like
this you're still scheduling it across
all those No
you've defined your micro service by
replica set in front end and it could be
all the stuff you know your go team is
happy your Jane ojs team is happy you're
not arguing about dependencies and
having religious wars about what
language to use and you can run all
these things together there's another
thing you probably want to do as you're
doing long term lifecycle of these micro
services there's that logging agent as
an example that's a cross-cutting
concern we got it out of our code our
developers don't think about anymore
they just write to log or whatever and
the logging agent picks it up from all
of them and sends it to our shared
repository Blundell did this a couple
weeks ago they've got a separate team
running these logging agent so it's time
to make a change we need to update that
could be a small change could be a big
one in the old world you've got to go to
all of those sixty teams and ask them
it's time to update your logging agent
please update this library in Java
please update this thing and if you're
lucky 20 of the teams have time on their
backlog to do it this week I mean if you
get done and 20 of the teams are in high
priority we're in crunch mode we're
launching something we'll get to it next
quarter and 22 teams say screw you guys
we like our own logging tools we're not
going to change and so you end up with
this really consistency across this
environment of these types of things
becomes hard so you just went to micro
services like oh yeah this is gonna be
great and now suddenly have a
consistency problem so in in the cue
brunette is landscape how this supports
your micro services is they just say
well let the team responsible for that
logging agent just says we're gonna
update that container in our registry we
are gonna define new pod templates for
every team that has the that has the new
logging agent and just easily with just
a couple of little automation like that
they've swiped out the old logging agent
and replaced it with their new logging
agent and they didn't have to take up
the head cycles the time of any of those
application developer teams those teams
could focus on what they're supposed to
do the next product the next feature so
that is I think the story of why
kubernetes is a great place for your
resilient micro services new stuff
coming out because we're short on time
we won't talk so much about
I'll give a link to it the new stuff
coming out is sto a service mesh what's
a service mesh imagine you had to build
HDPE retries and rate-limiting
encryption injecting SSL Certificates
you're a big enterprise you're a bank or
something you need consistency across
all of these things you can't just rely
on these cowboy developers and you and
anyway you don't want those application
developers to be thinking about that you
want them just to live there so you need
this consistency across your whole
landscape in the same model that we had
with the logging containers
you basically sto solves this problem in
a consistent way across your whole space
by injecting it into Cuban edits
kubernetes tio will run anywhere right
it's a partnership of it's a partnership
of IBM and Google teaming up Wow it's
the future and live to this crazy you
know taxi startup who supplied this
great level 7 load balancer so kind of
they teamed up like 17 years of
experience running services hung input
from hundreds of enterprises from Google
and IBM and this amazing low l7 load
balancer from live from from lyft
provide this environment essentially you
you will be able to run it anywhere
they've launched it in an open-source
method same way that we have from
kubernetes three and a half two and a
half three years ago I can see the same
momentum building up so today it's for
the bleeding edge people six months from
now you're gonna want to run it in your
own data center you know it's going to
be amazing if you want to get started I
found a really nice little getting
started around sto dot IO Doc's test so
you like this that ideas in general you
want to kind of get started on it
this is where I think you start G dot
cos code lab slash cloud has some really
nice container engine deployments which
and two hours you'll deploy your own
test micro service held two hours later
you can deploy your own micro service
using the same techniques we've also got
code lab boots out there to the back say
you're a.net developer he said I want to
try this magic there's a whole series
taking from a making a dotnet core
from from deploy simply to container
izing it to putting it into cuba netis
there's the testing also outback
training if your company says we want to
do this but we need training a bunch of
the partners out there provide training
or if you say we want to do this but we
need to jumpstart we need someone to
help us get moving
there's also partners out there that are
really really good at helping teach your
teams to do this you can do yourselves I
guess that's it exactly on time or no
I'm 20 minutes seconds over Thanks
[Applause]